attention aux apparences dans le
reportage que nous allons vous présenter
maintenant il y aura du sable du soleil
et de l'eau et cela peut évoquer bien
sûr la côte atlantique ou la côte de la
Méditerranée mais c'est à Saint-Quentin
dans l'INE loin de la mer que ces images
ont été tournées Sophie
Rolland la plage à domicile place de
l'Hôtel de Ville 800 tonnes de sable des
palmiers une piscine de 200 m² début
juillet l'été commençait plutôt bien
pour les cantinois le succès de l'an
dernier avait poussé la maie à
renouveler l'opération avec quelques
améliorations cette année on évolue déjà
dans un cadre beaucoup plus exotique
avec beaucoup plus d'évasion mais il y a
aussi plus de loisirs plus de sport vous
voyez derrière vous une vraie piscine
qui qui permet justement à tous les
enfants venus de tous les quartiers
d'avoir des loisirs totalement
gratuit mais il y a une semaine tempête
sur le sable la piscine est vidée raison
invoqué les contrôles sanitaires ont
découvert des bactéries dans l'eau
étonnement à la mairie selon elle toutes
les précautions nécessaires avec é
prise nous pensions qu'il suffisait de
renouveler complètement le bassin de le
nettoyer de font en compte de changer
les filtres des pompe ce qui a été fait
après nettoyages successifs la piscine a
puouvrir hier mais il ne reste que 5
jours pour profiter de l'eau à 18 de
l'opération se termine dimanche pas
facile d'improviser une plage quand on a
des
pavés